welcome to the F-word whether you're a
king cook or a kitchen virgin this is
definitely the place for
you on the menu tonight for our main
course the most popular bird in the
Country Chicken we reveal the
supermarket taking the most
responsibility for Shoppers Health the
results are not officially announced
until tomorrow but we have got the scoop
tonight and I teach Jonathan Ross how to
cook lobster if Paul mcart is watching I
apologize here and
the my mother and my dad that I love my
mother and I love my dad what have all
never had the F was here the F was b c
my mother and C my dad that I love my
mother and I love my dad want to have
all of
[Music]
never hi
guys okay s ready yes and ready on order
four covers table seven four Water Crest
soup main C four chicken yeah Jonathan
Ross watch that table please
yes now my two comments in the kitchen
this evening are first of all
22-year-old Shima she's actually from La
unfortunately second we have John from
greenu that's just outside glasgo in
fact where my parents are from that's
okay
Chef right tonight's starter is the most
amazing water crisp soup very simple
very straightforward and it's finished
with a delicious poached
egg Hot on all Water Crest
in then
season and I've got some thinly sliced
potatoes here I'm just going to sprinkle
thinly sliced potatoes over the top and
they're always like little sort of
crisps nice and transparent and very
thin and what this does to the soup it
almost gives it a little bit of texture
helps to thicken up a little
bit hot boiling water ready lightly
seasoned and just pour that over the
Water
Crest and all I'm going to do now is put
two or three little knobs of butter in
there and that butter gives us its
richness now the potatoes are cooked
within seconds the Water Crest is
sweated down it's going to take it off
now and Blitz it for 30 seconds this is
so easy anyone can do this at
home this really nice rich tasty made to
order Water Crest soup right now for the
poached
egg first of all get a whisk and just
gain some momentum in the water and what
this does as it starts to poach the egg
the egg white wraps around the egg yolk
so it forms like a mozzarella
ball I've crack my eggs into this mold
but you can put it in an espresso cup or
a teacup it just makes a lot easier for
dropping the egg into the water now the
water's going around that way so we put
the egg in that way ready and
in the most important thing is now the
momentum in the water's spinning around
so it's wrapping itself up in its own
egg white and the secret behind a good
poached egg is taking it out the water
water and putting it in ice water to
cool down and it stops it from
overcooking look at that lovely poached
egg into ice water and that cools it
down but look at the egg it's come out
like a really nice bowl of mozzarella
it's still nice and soft in the center
we're looking for that egg yolk to sort
of enrich the
soup lightly season
it and then soup yeah and just let it
run around naturally yeah
sure good leaf on top let's go now just
a touch of oil on there yes sure look
don't Square out just let it run around
naturally okay go table seven
please on appearance it was quite
surprising uh but on taste it contrasted
to that surpris it was really really
lovely I really enjoyed it and the poach
egg was perfect so yeah it was really
perfect start to what should hopefully
be a really good meal the soup was full
of flavor and then unexpected in the
middle a nice warm poached egg and it
complimented the the soup around it spot
on Mr ramsy how you doing Budd I'm very
good it's good to see you how yeah
likewise good to see you thank you for
having me here how's the soup not great
what do you mean not great it's a fresh
sou made to order I tell you what's
wrong with it exactly too hot too hot
too hot what do you mean peppering no
too hot I had a blow on it I find it
amazing that you've actually finished 2/
third of it now you start complaining
well because I'm a good guest I tell if
they came in a can I wouldn't buy it
again what went wrong tonight is it
pressure leav you're leaving your talent
on the
paver which is where the soup looks like
it came from look at the color that but
it's fresh is vibrant okay let me ask
you you know what it was nice but here's
the other thing as well is I'm hoping to
have sex with one of these people around
the table L on but now we've all got
green stuff in our teeth but now you got
to think ahead so that means you got
keep your mouth closed which is
difficult for you isn't it yeah of
course I can't be quiet last time I was
on your show yes sir you cooked for me
yes excellently I gave you a marvelous
octopi it was a disaster well the
octopus I was still tune on it 3 days
after I think it's still alive even
there and that was months ago if you had
one thing that You' ask me to sort of
help teach you to do what would it be
well okay I tell you what what what do
you think you know the raw material oh
God you've got someone here who's
burning with ambition I'm young I'm Keen
I'll put in the hours I know you chefs
work two or 3 hours a day
lobster properly that's a I do that hold
now hold it I wouldn't want to put it in
alive though do I have to put it when
it's alive it's the only way you can
identify it's fresh I can't do that
you've got to do it no no I got to break
that now you got to get a lobster in a
pot live I'll only eat one if I know
it's been run run over or died of old
age let me just show you now yes for 2
minutes a quick secret how to cook a
lobster properly I'll give it my best
shot good okay okay what okay sge we got
a new com in um and any idea how long I
be ding to see you in this look at the
size of it we I fit though what do I put
on first put that on there first
mate hey you know what I might wear this
home and scare Jane thinking I've got a
proper job again oh it's a it's a lie
I'm not eating that Hey listen if you
got the bollocks to eat it you should
have the bollocks to actually cook it
there you go right wait there two
seconds oh look he's not well this one
one thing
missing on that there you go there you
go
now you tell me if I look silly you he's
got a beard this got beard two seconds
make sure put that here Jesus Christ
he's
alive that's horrible that's a horrible
thing to do look at that he's waving he
wants to be friends have you seen this
you know what they're going to do to
these you okay with that why don't we
all just walk out why don't we just why
don't we just all Mutiny let's go now
right he's killing live lobsters here a
lot of people prefer to put that through
there knife through there look knife
through the cross yeah and then just
through there and straight through then
from there into the water so you've
eaten enough of them you know what I've
just realized I'm I'm on the
a it's good for do I you really want me
to kill your handle there but careful
don't hit too evil okay
you straight on up go open your eyes Jes
in the water I'm I'm like I feel like
I'm in the SAS now if Paul McCart is
watching I
apologize next on the menu as well as
Jonathan's Lobster killed with my own
Fair
hand and my main course of
chicken Gary the turkey comes face to
face with his namesake please keep him
alive and jars and I discover a very low
fat alternative to cow's milk oh that's
just absolutely
minging
welcome back to the fword so it's got
that nice pinky color now that's right
yeah that's where it starts go nice and
pink let's get it out I know here we go
I'm a chef that's right M You Don't
splash anyone when was last time you you
were actually in a kitchen in the
kitchen I cooked uh breakfast my little
bo this morning I cooked in boiled eggs
and toast does that count yeah it does
count not a prop a big meal though I
haven't done a puing meal for years
serious but Jane does it all get your
hand on there like that fresh lober
killed with my own Fair hands so what
that means now is a little glass of wine
good and what would be nice is actually
take it over and ask Gary to have a
little taste and tell him you cooked it
yeah and will you ask him what he thinks
about the soup okay does he need fingers
in fact I'll come with you come on I
have prepared this for you it's all
fresh there's nothing on it we would
like you to try and see what you think
Jonathan Ross's first ever live lobster
killed and cooked what do you think yeah
sweet freshh very fresh you quite tasty
sang to it while I was killing it and
that I think got it in the right mood
for brutal murder and immersing in
boiling water that is the most succulent
L tasting better than at that place in
was it called Hospital Road so uh and
this presumably is better than the soup
you had it this evening which I thought
wasn't very good what do you think of
the soup what was it I'm going to get on
the main course and try to keep you guys
happy yes I'm going to go and come up
with a new recipe for start you go back
to your table I'll see you in I want to
know what's going on with Gary yes of
course thank you I might wash my hands
I've got Lobster blood on
[Music]
it next up is our main course it's a
chicken that's been poached and sauteed
served with pom puree and caramelized
turnips basically chicken a
mash chicken perhaps the most popular
bird in Britain remove legs Wings
Parson's
nose stuff with garlic and
[Music]
salt poaching stock carrots celery
leaks pepper and
coriander th
Bailey poach 12
minutes morel mushroom sauce if you
can't find morels use a dried sep or
just a dried wild mushroom
shots salt
thme
garlic 100 G dried
Morales we get some flavor on
there I much prefer using dried
mushrooms because gives it a lot of
intensity white
wine
reduce remove
chicken add
stock
150 Ms double
cream and the secet this sace of course
is getting it to almost like a cafe Olay
[Music]
color we squeeze all that juice out of
there parsley into the
sauce okay remove chicken breast get
your knife point it on top of the
wishbone and go through it
beautiful breast
season hot pan olive
oil skin TI down
first just really nice and
crispy
butter
base chicken with morel mushroom sauce
done now poaching the chicken and then
soing actually helps to keep the breast
nice and moist and we all know what
dried chicken tastes like there's
nothing worse so the idea of potion at
first is to render the fat down then is
put in the pan soed and it keeps the
color and gives the skin a really nice
flavor little bit of butter in there now
start getting some color on there bit of
sugar that's right now we're serving
turnips with a chicken and what really
pisses me off is that people are so rude
about turnips they're full of flavor a
great winter vegetable and we're going
to be caramelizing these with some
Chinese F spice as the turnips soften I
drain off the fat and add a good dousing
of Port this glazes the turnips and as
it reduces they turn a great color let's
go John more pork little bit
butter yeah warn me when you're doing
that with the turnips I'm also serving
mashed potato now some people use very
fluffy and flowy potatoes but I'm using
a nice waxy potato to help take on more
cream and butter the secret behind
making a great Mash for me personally is
keeping the skins on the skins protect
the potato so therefore it doesn't
absorb all that water and we peel them
when they're piping
hot never be tempted to make a mashed
potato in a food processor that turns
into like a gluey horrible mess I use
hot milk and a riser to make the mash a
lot of people take the potatoes off the
stove at this stage but I use a low heat
to cook off any excess water and melting
the
butter there we go four here Mark six
first and don't don't burn that butter
sheima watch that butter doesn't burn
there yes M four and then six yes
yes hello ra hello good to see you
welcome back jles hello Gordon how was
the soup the soup tasted healthy very
healthy green like a plunger go through
you really liven things up I'm sure the
other plers did you enjoy yourself yeah
oh I loved it yeah now um last week you
did a report for us on Supermarket
sausages I did you've been back there
this week I've been back to the
supermarkets because this this week it
is the National Consumer council's
annual Supermarket survey which is
something that all the supermarkets get
very excited about it's almost like the
sort of miching guard very competitive
very competitive and uh but aren aren't
they aren't they all just aren't they
just the same Super Market well you you
say that but for instance this year they
went out they bought 12 uh basic items
from all of the supermarkets between the
highest and the lowest salt content
there was 22% so they're not all the
same so who's won this year well the
results are not officially announced
until tomorrow but we have got the scoop
tonight in Britain we spend an average
of
1,745 per person each year in
supermarkets that's 85% of the money we
all spend on food this means the
supermarkets play a pivotal role in
shaping the health of the nation we've
got a real problem with our diet in this
country over half of us are either
overweight or obese and year on year
those numbers are increasing so here at
the F-word we got into bed with the NCC
to find out how much responsibility our
supermarkets take for the nation's
Health every year they do a spot check
survey of the top nine we've looked at
12 key Foods everyday Foods in stores
around the country and the way in which
supermarkets promote the foods to us and
we have now rated them for how much they
care about our health or whether really
they're just competing on price the NCC
looked at Salt levels in each Retailer's
own brand Foods as well as judging them
wider factors such as clear labeling the
promotion of healthy eating and whether
or not they keep sweets at the
checkout so which Supermarket would
people guess comes in last place in the
survey SS
free
as in bottom place this year is the
non-nonsense northerner of supermarkets
Morrison's we looked at Salt levels in
10 everyday foods and we found that
Morrison came out with some of the
saltiest Foods on sale Morrison's
advertising slogan is more reasons to
shop at Morrison's well a high level of
salt in your own Brand Products is one
reason to shop elsewhere in response to
the survey Morrison said the NCC report
is inaccurate and does not present a
true reflection of our approach to
health responsibility failing to
recognize the progress we have made we
have introduced our eat Smart healthy
eating range and extended our better
because brand in addition to an ongoing
robust salt Reduction Program focused on
the most popular products sold in stores
in joint eighth and Seventh Place a
Summerfield in Iceland who both score
poorly on customer information on
healthy eating I think they could do a
lot better in sixth place we have the
giant of the High Street the Jugger food
stores Tesco Tesco's score was
disappointing they're the biggest
retailer they take nearly one in three
of every pounds that we spend in
supermarkets on food we found Tesco weak
across the board apart from having no
sweets at the check out they didn't
score highly in any of the areas that we
looked at Tesco say in their adverts
that every little helps looking at these
results that's certainly true if they
made just a few small changes Tesco
could have an enormous impact on the
nation's
Health AA has improved more than most
and is up from Seventh to fifth place
they have the least salty economy range
of foods which is really important for
those people shopping on a budget
disappointing news for sabes who dropped
two places to number four with the
saltiest cheese and tomato pizza of all
nine retailers no wonder we can taste
the difference but in spite of this
Saints are still the best of the big
four
supermarkets in joint's second and third
place are the two Posh supermarkets waos
and Mars and
Spencers Mars and Spencers are very good
at promoting healthy food nearly a third
of their special offers are on fruit and
veg waitr was number one last year but
they've been knocked off the top spot by
a surprise
winner according to the ncc's new report
the number one supermarket in Britain
is the
co-op they really care about our health
and they're not an upmarket Supermarket
they have a high proportion of budget
conscious Shoppers and they're showing
all the retailers that it's possible
it's possible to make those changes that
are going to make a difference for all
of us so according to the survey what
they say in their ads May well be true
at least in terms of health
responsibility Co-op we go further so
you don't have to so if you want your
local supermarket to make more effort to
promote healthy eating visit the fword
website and see how you can have your
voice
heard a surprising winner the K I know
it's amazing isn't it I was really
surprised what worried you most about
the results I think it's quite shocking
that not one of the big fours in the top
three of this list yeah and do you
actually think that you know a survey
like this actually helps the Shoppers
yeah cuz I think the more information
you have uh the better informed you are
when you make your choice also I think
for you know thinking about next year
it's going to encourage this the other
supermarkets to be more healthy because
they won't want to be beaten by the
co-op hum old Co-op no but I mean would
the other supermarkets the big big big
players take this result badly yeah I
think they really really care about
publicity and this is bad publicity yeah
well none of us like bad publicity and
thank you
[Music]
interesting okay John wait chicken slice
and bow the sauce let's go right
Shima grab hand your sh good nice
scooper pomp in there John nav round
please three or four right get it like
that me okay and on we got try and keep
it the same sort of shape as a chicken
breast in cut away and go again yes yes
let's go come on you be a little bit
more generous than that John fall on
there
please good for
you chicken
on like this and open up the breast yes
on and open up the breast good go
everybody you sending a separate Mark
yeah let's
go open up come on sham it's too slow
come
on we're right in the midd of the
service now yeah we're not at the
cookery school now yeah let's go right
sauce over go speed up a little bit
let's go right table please service
table 14 yeah come on now less sauce
less sauce less sauce come on oh dear oh
dear table 14 please yes the idea of the
sauce shamer is to compliment it yet not
drown it yeah yeah sure let's
[Applause]
[Music]
go the mashed potato is very buttery and
smooth and delicious and the turnips a
good contrast cuz it's very crunchy and
kind of goes nicely with the chicken
which is very tender and and and
delicious love it love it it's like it's
like some sort of winter warmer meal
perfect for this evening it's like
mashed potato creamy Saucy yumy really
all
good hello buddy how are you how's the
main course I enjoyed the main course go
on I enjoyed the M good sauce yes good
pom puree yes nice chicken lovely moist
but you had these little three Surplus
bit around the outside which sort of
sort of like faking itself as nav as
turnips and couldn't see the
relationship between the turnip and
anything else personally it's vegetable
that everyone forgets about this time I
think it's a fat BGE more important
how's how's Gary put these on and just
just have a little look at him Gary is
my turkey I've been looking after him
we'll name him after chefs yours is
called Gary that's the one with a spiky
bum there's Gary look I have to say
he's very very handsome to be honest
yours does actually look like you he
does the
neck you got I tell you watch it mate
watch it at the beginning Gary and iell
were best friends they even had their
dinner together and Gary got really ill
it's called Bumble foot if the medicine
doesn't work Gary is going to have to be
put down it's the first time I've seen
you concerned about me in all these
years now I've always been concerned you
know I have they broke cup friends and
nigela started picking on him she she's
always on there I was really excited
when we found out that Gary was better
the good news is I think he's made
it we didn't know if Gary was a boy
turkey or a girl turkey Gary is a man
yeah which is good news I think it's
good news for Gary yes myel is
definitely a boy she's not an i Jello
she's an
Nel
no oh I can't believe my daughter's is
kissing Gary give me please One Promise
please one small promise Gordon I'll
love you forever in fact more than I
already do go keep him alive keep him
alive kill the other come on please keep
him alive your children have looked
after him he there to e cud him they you
know all extra hay and the straw he he's
been are you getting softer in your old
age next on the menu my campaign to get
women back in the kitchen recruits a
mother from Wales hello brand new pan
never been used before and Jonathan Ross
shows off his latest kitchen gadget from
Japan you're having a laugh no you're
bullshitter that's one my favorite meal
no come on look at it for God's sake
looks like a fried pan of baby
[Applause]
stick now it's time for pudding this
week three firemen are going to try and
take me on with their favorite chocolate
cheesecake pudding when we heard golden
was up for a challenge we knew the three
of us together could wipe the floor with
him because there's not enough uh love
in his food there's loads of love in El
he's just an angry man and I think he's
he produces angry food this is the first
time we've had three against one however
it's fine I've had 25 against one and
still come out on top so if we beat you
then you're going to come to the station
to cook us some meal exactly that I'm
actually going to be making a really
nice perm and chocolate cheesecake now
the most intriguing thing about this
particular cheesecake is not cooked I
don't actually like cooking a cheesecake
cheesecake is something that should be
fresh vibrant and sometimes when you
cook it it tends to be a little bit
soggy in the Center and it's not really
a cheesecake if it's cooked is it
they're doing a chocolate cheesecake
that's cooked for hour and 20 minutes
right what I'm going to do now is uh add
the masap pon cheese and some fromage
fry give them a quick
whisk get that nice and smooth
now let grab the chocolate now just fold
it nice and gently uh it does give you a
better mixture and it comes out superb
so start off by peeling the
pears and once they're peeled put them
straight into sugar and water that's
basically called a stock syrup and then
all you do there is just gently poach
the pears for about 8 to 10
minutes how's it going not bad not bad
we're well on track now the secret
behind this dish is what Ginger Ginger
where's a cheesecake with ginger sounds
disgusting apparently you nicked it out
Jamie Oliver's book is that right no it
actually deia deia's book not another
one cuz how much chocolate's going in
there uh 150 g 150 g yeah yeah what I've
done here is pasted the Philadelphia
cheese with the sugar and vanilla and
that fresh vanilla it looks like little
tiny blobbles of sort of pepper but what
it does it actually perfumes and sort of
lightens up the whole cheesecake because
there's nothing worse than eating a
cheesecake that's very
[Music]
stodgy what's in there Ginger biscuits
Ginger biscuits just Ginger biscuits
crusted I'm not going to say too much
Gordon just in case I'm going to do a
little bit of stealing right Nick it
Nick it for my base I'm using brand
flakes that's brought together with some
melted chocolate you just get two pieces
of Grease Booth paper and then take your
mixture and just place it onto the
grease witho paper and just roll that
just as you would rolling pastry and
look it starts to layer this really nice
thin biscuit get your cutter and place
your cutter there just place that into
the fridge 5 minutes and that'll be a
really nice firm biscuit base ready for
a cheesecake nail in the fridge please
while the base is setting in the fridge
slice the poach pear and add to the
cheese and chocolate mixture then after
5 minutes
look nicely lined biscuit base once the
base has set pipe the mixture into the
mold once you filled up the mold with
the mixture they go into the fridge for
about 8 to 10 minutes to set all pulled
B is ready now what I'm going to do is
add my mixture to the uh biscuit base
I'll place all that in
there now that is ready to go right in
the oven for an hour and a
quarter okay come on dear oh dear um
enjoy your main course I did enjoy my
main course yes yes I have the turnips
the caramelized turnips really yeah come
on like an apple because of all the
sugar and then it sort of Falls away you
always have to find something to sort of
nitpick just like like a frost bit turn
tastes like an apple it was like a
frostbit an apple it's just cuz you
caramelized it it was sweet I thought it
was been too many bins mate you know
that you've been diving deep in too many
black bags yeah I think that's probably
what it is and are you a big fan of I
certainly am why good cuz that's what
I've been cooking this week as part of
my campaign to get women back in the
kitchen
I'm a mother and a full-time employee I
can't cook very well at all it's
becoming a real problem and I feel
terrible I feel like I'm letting my
family down Ian is very hard done by he
has a physical job he's burning a lot of
calories and instead of me building him
up and off he goes and comes in after a
good day's work is the other way around
and the weight's just falling off him
this is me when I just after I met
Shelly 14 Stone there and now due to the
cooking I'm down to char Stone I would
love Gordon ramsy my hero in the kitchen
to come and sort me out just sort me
[Music]
out good morning hello how are you fine
thank you so what is it yeah it's just
also difficult and complicated and I
haven't got a lot of time and when
you've got the children sitting around
the
table you know and every mouthful is
forced it's like well we just have beans
on toast then nice collection of pens I
like those and I bought those um because
they were silver and everything was
silver and chrome yeah that's bought
them but what do you use them for no I
don't really and what's it like for
Sunday lunch we never have one you never
have a Sunday lunch so you eat out for
Sunday lunch lunch so eating out every
Sunday lunch must be expensive it is
yeah it is it's ridiculous really we
can't really carry on so that's what we
got to get Mom to do really just cook a
perfect Sunday dinner right roast Leo
lamb um Lely love grat and Doin What
does that mean to you gratt and do from
was something potato is that's right
potatoes you know what that is don't you
um it's not
mint that's Rosemary that's Rosemary
there you go okay I want you to cut some
sprigs like this
and then what we're going to do now is
just make some some holes take the
Rosemary and just push it through it in
so we got rosemary garlic in there okay
good salt pepper drizz it with olive oil
over the top that's it in you go good
okay if you just stuck it in the tray in
the
oven you're just going to create
something dry we got to get some color
in there it's called sealing it in this
is quite basic what you mean is you want
it to go Brown nice and brown right
thank you yes going to put that in there
nice sharp knife that's what we need
yeah when was the last time you
sharpened them I've never sharpened them
you've never sham your knife no but they
are right for birthday cake they do the
job for that but I don't know which side
to do I turn it up that way and slice or
just slice it that way or that way okay
so stand here let me just show oh God so
go from left from there from my thumb
here right to the top and then come
underneath and all you do now is put an
edge back on the
knife yeah yeah slowly slowly that's it
the secret is of course it all to come
out at the same time and what I'm trying
to do is just get everything arriving
together okay add look brand new pan
never been used before half cream and
half milk that's come up to the boil
right I want you to get a spoon and just
taste that M very nice yeah okay
sprinkle cheese at the bottom right okay
and then push the potatoes
down right pour in there just to start
seeing it underneath the potatoes right
that's good now the rest with the cheese
on top I'm trying to spread it evenly
cuz what we want to do is get that
really nice nice crust on top and then
we go don't drop it now careful careful
careful careful careful that's not
supposed to happen no that's not no no
bit clumsy s dear oh dear oh dear okay
potatoes the potatoes the most important
thing about these is just having the
fork go through and if it goes through
with ease what does that tell you
they're
done the house smells fantastic it does
it never smells like this okay in with a
broccoli are we hungry yeah
oh
[Music]
good this smells
lovely I mean that just the perfect mean
to V yeah yeah look at
that you like it guys
yeah
tasty beautiful see filling out already
mate really nice is huge buy a new
wardrobe now do you feel better now
definitely definitely I've got more
confidence to go on to do that again
excellent what about a round of applause
for mommy yeah thank you thank you momy
and uh bye and don't give up I won't
keep that confidence High okay yes thank
you
bye it's the Moment of Truth for our
chocolate cheesecakes right gentlemen
are we ready y we are yes Born Ready
Born Ready BN ready here we go
okay happy yes yeah good luck okay JP
upstairs service please
go okay so Shantel yeah you get dessert
number one in front of
you our blind tastes tonight are all
professional chocolate sellers tasters
or manufacturers so they should know
what they're talking
about yeah there's ginger in the um
something next to it's nice like this
kind of Rish slightly yeah off you know
creem fresh T okay so now we go for
dessert number
two thank
you m more chocolatey yes yeah
definitely maybe a bit of Honey or
something in there yeah base is actually
quite difficult to Grapple with isn't it
well I like the texture of it okay guys
it's time for for the verdict for the
results result time feeling nervous no
no look at him smiling back there must
have a little bit of buzz in your tummy
okay okay guys results are in yes are
good it's been quite hard actually this
week what you mean it quite hard no no
it's very close very close actually but
the winner is today
yeah what doing F
[Applause]
man hold on a minute what can I say
right here we go now they can cook as
well not only are they Heroes but they
can cook as well well done guys thank
you close call yes what done big boy
thank you close call yes [__] so I can
smell burning now back to work yes dear
oh dear well done you're confident all
the way weren't you big boy yes big man
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
[Music]
[__] you need a hot flat plate that's
all this makes it look complicated
really it's just for people but once you
got those ingredients it's just like
making it's a bit like bubble and squeak
right enjoy the main course main course
was great well done you have redeemed
yourself thank God for that as good
summer Gary stuff I
mean wow that's a nice thing to say
listen yes you you got a lot of pets at
home too many yeah and far too many two
of them are lambs I know you like them
we've got anig Guana we have five fets
we have one python we have now we had
three dogs we now have four dogs and my
wife got from a birthday three cats I'm
not going to eat the dogs no they only
do that in Korea for the Lambs you going
to eat the Lambs no we're not the the
Lambs are pets Molly and muffin they're
very sweet you can't have Lambs as pets
cuz you know we've got turkeys in the
garden for the kids to grow their own
Christmas L here's the thing I found
strange when I was watching this show
last week is one of the turkeys was a
bit unwell you were saying oh the
children upset the turkey might die yeah
you're going to kill the turkey next
week why are the children going to come
with that never mind call the vet he got
a bad finish it off now it's not fat
enough
yet he can't keep his hands off it's
like we're back in jail no no but you
can't you can't kill something that's
not actually ready you know that no but
I got got really bad news what's that
myel is a man no one eats like that well
I have long suspected that because her
hands and the Adams Apple were dead
giveaway she's 12 and half kilo oh I
love it more cushion for the pushing you
know what I'm saying I got more bad news
de a man as
well yeah that's not such bad news
really cuz none of us were thinking
about that I can't believe you talk so
quickly for God's sake how do you get
word in edgeways you don't need to get
word just relax and learn all right I
have a lot to teach you so you're
fascinated by food aren't you I'm
fascinated by food your parents met in
the restaurant they did they were
working they were looking at the r are
you actually thinking about getting into
this no not remotely I've watched a
little show called I can't remember it's
called I think it's for Jam's Kitchen
Nightmares it's something like that
anyway he's very good he goes in and he
rescues an Al in business right you
should watch it uh and I know it looks
to me like it's bloody hard work I
didn't get into TV to work hard right
okay okay now you know I don't want to
be on my feet all you're quite natural
you're you're comfortable in front of
your stove what is this Fearless with an
egg this is called ayaki which is
Japanese phrase more or less literally
translated as eat what you like it's
kind of a fast food over there very
popular it's like a student food it's
like pizza it's much better for you you
put the egg straight into the mix okay
and then you scge it all up and you and
you do this in the restaurant it's good
fun it's a fun part it's a great place
to eat with kids if ever you find
yourself you know on a wayday weekend in
Tokyo a cabbage omelet essentially yes
but wait and see you will be hold on a
minute 10 minutes ago you hating my soup
now you want me to actually get excited
about what you're doing once you try
this they'll be serving this in clares
you know in both restaurants bollocks a
little bit goes on the hot and sizzling
thing this isn't quite hot enough but
while we're waiting for that to cook
quick question yeah is it's been known
that you uh you sort of you know love
feeding Jane and sort of I love feeding
Jane getting her nice and plump I would
like her to be well covered for
Christmas ideally yes but why do you
keep on stuffing her like that why do
you not just let her eat what she wants
to eat as opposed to you force feeding
her treating her like a goose it's okay
well I okay I have been known to put
stuff in her mouth while she's asleep
okay but then then aren't all us men
guilty of that no at least allow them to
stay away that food now gold it's
getting there now I got I just say it
looks disgusting right well you say that
and you need plain like that no you have
different things you put on it okay
you'll find out right there a barbecue
salce you put on this is when it gets
this this is why it's good gungy food
look lot of that on right okay no no no
then you oh look can you can you see
what it is yet can you tell what it is
looks like a tur now you a flatten you
are familiar with noi this is the master
stroke right what is that mayonnaise
different Japanese don't eat mayonnaise
blood oh look at that oh look at that do
that look good dear oh dear help
yourself do a little bit of that cut a
charge a bit off okay okay you are going
to love it flipping neck have you eaten
in a Japanese
restaurant sorry like it
that do you honestly like that
too you're you're having a laugh that's
food no you're bullshitting that's one
of my favorite meals no come on look at
it for God's sake looks like a fried pan
of Babys sick I can e two in one
sitting
good to see you good to see you always
pleasure yeah you know to finish this
off nicely some
biscuits a bit of cheese wouldn't kill
you would it a bit of cheese now it's
understandably why you didn't like my
waterest soup is this it this is all get
here I'm starving you can't send me home
like this I tell you what a Jamie's
place you get
biscuits next on the menu J's coron
milks a horse oh it feels like a warm
scoten and the cies find out who who's
staying and who's going home if I really
had to sort of you know now decide I'm
one person staying I'm one person going
home
[Applause]
um welcome back to the
fword well I actually was surprisingly
really impressed by the dessert soz I
thought it was a really nice blend it
was chewy it was crunchy it had
smoothness it was really really nice it
didn't melt in my mouth you know like
the mashed potato that was fantastic but
the dessert wasn't wasn't for me at all
um Charles do you enjoy your pudding not
enormously no but St a little bit yeah I
mean but then again I wouldn't enjoy
being rescued from a fire by a chef so
why would I enjoy eating a pudding made
by a fireman frankly was it made with
organic chocolate yes it was but you're
obsessed with Organics I'm not obsessed
I'm part of a growing Trend everybody's
into it organic milk sales of rocketed
not just CR people Once Upon a Time milk
was just good for you it had a lot of
bottle it was nice cold ice cold milk
pure and simple and then people decided
it had too much fat and cholesterol and
we had to start drinking skin milk and
then it had bad chemicals in it and we
had to go organic and then there were
lactose intolerant people and they had
to drink soy milk and then in the
supermarket there was goats milk and
buffalo milk well here in Belgium where
most exciting things in the world start
as everybody knows they're milking
something even more unusual horses
horses milk contains less than half the
fat of whole cow's milk and according to
its many Belgian fans is better for for
you all
around in Britain the search for
healthier food has seen organic milk
sales Rise by 77% in the last year but
hse's milk surely that couldn't happen
here so first we clean the nipples it's
very important then it is very important
and they're very very big aren't they
they are very big yeah you want to try
it oh that's just absolutely
minging it's quite odd reaching in under
a horse and touching her tips yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah she just flinched though
when I touched it it's very soft oh God
Almighty that feels
terrible oh it feels like a warm
scoten in Belgium they've got 36 HSE
dairy farms and production is increasing
at a rate of 40% a year uh last year we
had to buy uh 10 more mes to help all
our customers so we started 9 years ago
with four mes and now we have almost 100
mes so uh it grows very quickly and what
why why is so popular then what's so
good about HSE milk why it's so popular
uh most of the people drink it for
health problems many people who have
problems with the intestines uh stomach
problems skin diseases uh also many
children who cannot drink cow milk uh
they can drink the horse milk but don't
cancel your cow's milk order just yet
there are various claims have been made
on hores milk for example that it helps
to improve skin conditions and it's
reduced in fat I haven't seen any strong
scientific evidence that convinces me
that horse's milk would be a good
treatment for any of these disorders in
terms of it's reduced fat content yes it
has a lower fat content than cow's milk
and I can see that would offer some
appeal to some people and then of course
there's the issue of
taste no milk today for you oh God it
had very very little taste at all it's
like skim milk um the it comes to a
little bit cheesy afterwards it's a bit
like there a like like a like after
you've eaten Bree the kind of burp you
might do come through a kind of you know
a kind of but it's not sour so what was
it like milking a horse very strange
I've never milked anything else so I I
can't really compare it but it was an
extremely strange sensation and you got
to sort of massage you got to jiggle and
jiggle and jiggle and then attach it to
a machine I would have said you're mad
but you know 10 years ago hardly any
Supermarket sort of stock water now when
you look at the variety of waters in
supermarket I'm sure milk is going to be
exactly the same so I went to a
supermarket to find out what people
actually thought about horse milk would
you like a glass of milk in the morning
no it's actually horse's
milk no it can
be oh no even not can drink that no low
and cholesterol my cats won't like
that what' you reckon tastes nice any
idea what it is it's hores
milk
tasted like baby's milk tastes like
baby's milk interesting yes that breast
milk is it see that's what I said to him
he said isn't it he can't remember he
was not there that long hey I love your
hairstyle you know that have you ever
heard of Gary rhods have you ever heard
of him no nor of I take care I must say
you look a lot thinner in real life it's
all on the back of this horse milk half
the fat of cow's
milk now the key thing for me being a
chef of course is what it actually
tastes like and secondly more
importantly what is it actually like to
cook with so I'm going to make a very
simple straightforward rice
pudding I was actually quite skeptical
about using Hors milk in this rice
pudding but over the last 3 or 4 minutes
as it's cooking down the rice has stared
to form this lovely sort of glossy coat
almost like it's sort of looking quite
luxurious that's because the Hors milk
has reduced in strength it started to
put a really nice glaze on the rice and
it's natur sweeten the rice pudding
which is a big Advantage who would have
thought Hors milk can actually make a
delicious creamy perfect rice pudding
look at it that is amazing right little
treat for you oh thank you
yes one each I'm dying to find out what
you actually think about
it I'm worried why because if you're
dying to find out what I think about it
that Mak something's wrong it's a rice
pudding it reminds me the first taste
like really eggy custard ready yeah it's
really nice and D what do you
think it's quite nice but it's quite
Rich right it's richer than than like
any other rice pudding I have it's
actually been made with you believe with
horsey milk with which has half the fat
of cow's
milk Hy what's the sperm
count it's I'm not eating I'm not
putting that my mouth listen I tried
that disgusting omelette now eat it and
shut up not an OM it's a Kaki all right
here we go did you make this yes it's
rice
pudding good this will be nice of
Christmas there a bit of cognac in there
a bit of vanilla yeah that's right yeah
done well
spotted bit of
cheese now that's Sor that's was in my
tooth from earlier what kind of milk do
you think that's been made
with that's tasty mother's milk
it's horse milk rice
pudding made with hor when you say milk
that's not a
euphemism can you milk a
horse who milked the
horse how come you got me to kill a
lobster when there's a horse that needs
milking Jo's Corin I know my way around
a nipple Jes Corin milked the horse yeah
not for the first time I bet have a
taste is this it this is it fres Hest ex
fresh it's lacking in flavor you don't
think it's nice well it's not got the
flavor of a cows milk so horsse milk is
the next big thing not for me but uh but
I you know I appreciate the work you're
doing there you got a steak in it as old
is is you're trying to make some money
I'll see you again soon I hope so but
not with any of this
stuff welcome to the fword I'm cooking a
three course dinner for 60 diners all
stuff you can do at home on the menu
tonight for our main course Beef
Wellington H Bernie whitting stor comes
to visit my urban farm and give me
advice on how to get the kids ready for
the big day taking tell me to slaughter
is an emotional occasion you can't sort
of totally put that out the way and Kim
and agie get down and dirty in my
kitchen
[Music]
now dad I love my mother and I love my
dad have all never had the here
the my mother and I C my dad but I love
my mother and I love my dad want to have
all never
easy okay guys right abass you're
struggling to talk today what's the
matter nervous Che nervous nervous
nervous is a good sign yes are you
nervous [__] myself [__]
yourself so am I yeah I do every time
yeah before service okay good luck
concentrate wake up and I want to hear
you a little bit yes yes sure tonight's
starter is a salad of roasted sea
scallops with a cauliflower puree and a
caper raisin dressing turn them now back
on the heat every time you take that pan
off what's happening losing losing the
heat so they're going to boil it come on
my two com this week are AB bass who's
24 he was born in Iraq grew up in London
and worked in a French restaurant I
don't want you to be moody or stoppy I
want you to be concentrated on what
you're doing nothing more than that yeah
and try and keep your nose out the way
and Tama who's just 18 years of age T
has been working in his dad's kosher
restaurant since he was 11 now you're
not the smallest of cooks so you're
endangered of being clumsy so on your
toes like a ballerina yes at the end of
the day one will go home and the other
will come back to compete for a job in
my kitchen can they stand the heat on
order six covers table 11 six salad of
sea sculps main call six Beef Wellington
on crude
yes didn't hear you Tama yes chef that's
better thank you how many scet for
portion uh three in Che so six pieces
that's right 6 threes are 6 threes 18
too late wake up
always try to buy sculps that are
actually in their show CU it's a great
guarantee to how fresh they
are now to open up a scul up it's quite
easy you get your knife and you push
that through that tiny little Gap and
just twist and once you've opened the
shell get the top of the knife and just
slide against the top of the shell and
look what happens the shell comes up
there you go now the only piece of the
skull that we're interested in is this
white part here slide your thumb down
the muscle and pop it out of its skirt
this orange beak the coral it's called I
don't really like cooking with them
because they taste of nothing and they
get very rubbery it's not worth it get
rid of the orange part and just cook
that nice white pearl the easiest way to
cut a scul up in half is look at this
flat bit here and then just find out
halfway and what that does if you're
halfway there it cuts the scallop
exactly into half look how fresh they
are they're still moving they're still
pulsating that's the only way to eat
scallops open up in your hand like that
yeah and then in the seasoning here we
got half curry powder half salt and when
you season always season from a height
so it spreads across it okay let's go
four scallops into the
pan scallops in
12:00 that's it there you go by the time
we get down to 6:00 we know exactly
where to turn the scolars okay off the
heat watch and turn yes sure good look
how fresh these scops are let's go and
less olive oil in there next time yeah
what you doing now Tam is you're
actually boiling the scul as opposed to
soting it okay yeah sure yeah back on
the Heat come on you're losing the heat
in the pan right stop stop stop stop
tell me the difference between those
scops and those sculps they less those
come on then I want them start again get
them in the bin and start
again I can't serve two portions nicely
done and two portions that have been
boiled now turn around and work together
a little bit yes take your time I'm
serving the sculps on a delicious
cauliflower puree now cook them in
butter for about 2 to 3 minutes till
they go nice and soft and then we're
going to add some milk and what the milk
does it actually helps keep the puree
really nice and vibrant white now as
that milk starts to boil we're going to
finish it with a touch of
cream and now we're going to cook that
out about another 3 or 4 minutes and
then puree it's really important to
blend this when it's really nice and hot
so therefore the hotter it is the finer
it becomes if you leave it to cool down
then you'll get lumps through it so make
sure that you always blend it when it's
hot okay now
look what's inside this really nice rich
creamy smooth cauliflower
puree that will beat cauliflower and
cheese any day how many scolars you got
per portion six per portion okay good
watch watch me cauliflower puron then
the Caper raisin vinegarette watch it's
very strong yeah it's very tasty very
Tangy now we get the sweetness of the
scallops on there on top of the cifi
puree presentation is crucial the less
elements in a dish the more important it
is to Plate it upright right stop stop
there okay you're not listening to me
you're going to round the outside of the
plate again yeah there you put them on
the scallops set on top of the
cauliflower puree let's start again yeah
Third Time Lucky I want you to really
think about how much money we're wasting
and I want you seriously to wake up and
get a grip this is the same table we're
doing for the third time yes yes chef
this doesn't go out properly one of you
going home don't worry about waiting
till later oil in the pan let's
go dear oh dear just drizzle that round
there like that now look at yours look
at mine tell me the
difference you've gone out round the rim
of the plate customers don't want to eat
off the rim of the plate you come in
next time get it right okay clean the
plate let's
[Applause]
go it was amazing we we spent the first
two minutes trying to figure out what
all the different flavors were and
having various guesses um we actually
guessed mashed potato without the CIF
flow but the over overwhelming flavor
was the Capers um and and the sweetness
in that and it just complimented the
scallops it was fantastic the
cauliflower puree is is lovely I've
never thought of puree and cauliflower
before but that's it really works really
well with the SC it's very
nice ladies good to see you how are you
I'm good how are you you enjoyed your
Scholars thank they were lovely but not
quite my palette you just you don't like
sculps I mean just not my palette really
where have the corals gone you know
every time I see restaurant serving
coals of sculps I get out because it's a
cheap skate identification they taste
very oh I love them they're so rich
they're so creamy I want the corals give
me the corals I don't know what she's
talking about I think more importantly
they take twice as long to cook than
they do with the white meat and by the
time the corals cooked the scarps
overcook so okay ladies what do you look
for when you're walk into a restaurant I
mean hygiene wise well everything I
don't like Cutlery that's been T that's
all got water mark I can't stand it okay
everything's got and I can't stand stem
glass they been stored and there's
always dust here I can't stand that and
clean l k you want to come see me yeah
come on I do because these always let
restaurants down now Gordon dear you
know you may be a a famous chef but
you've got to inspect the lose
dear I can't believe you put your head
down there get in there I'm not going to
put my head get in the get in there
what's it like there there you go I mean
it looks quite clean you actually smells
quite clean that's clean you happy that
one there only pee PE on the SE
how can you spot pee peee underne
because you turn sideways the shine it's
all peeee stains you're doing a good job
here okay door hand Juna I've got to say
I'm I'm highly impressed you're happy
with the toilets they're clean are you
rushing me out of here are we going to
go back to the dining room get out get
out doing your favor you haven't washed
your hands you've come out the toilet
and you haven't washed your hands that
excuse me I've not come out yet dear
next on the menu along with our main
course of beef
wellington I don't believe it Richard
Wilson's in the house Jonathan Ross paid
me £10,000 to s I'm
sorry okay new potatoes in first we'll
start soting do not forget to take out
the garlic yes sir welcome back to the f
word next up our main course a real
classic Phil it of beef wellington with
sauteed potatoes and wilted baby Jem
lettuce
this beef fill it lean meat with little
fine sen of fat running through it just
melts in your mouth like butter
seasoned hot pan olive
oil
seal
mustard think about it fet beef w
Wellington English mustard you're not
going to put Deon on there are
you
mushrooms
season
Blitz now I got to take the water out
the mushrooms look how wet they are we
don't put oil or butter into the pan we
put nothing in
there look how much water's coming out
now
assemble cing film Palmer
ham
mushrooms beef
Center and
roll twist it nice and tight chill 20
minutes puff
pastry beef
unwrap on to the pastry egg
wash don't skip on the egg wash now cuz
we really need it to
[Music]
stick tuck that in chill 5
minutes
Blaze
score rock
salt
bake
[Music]
the most important thing about F of beef
Wedington do not slice it thinly okay
turn it
around and slice it about an inch
thick beef
wellington
done and lettuce goes in at the last
minute okay lettuce just tastes
literally 20 seconds to wiel nice hot
pan don't get it too oily now with the
beef wellington we're serving saute
potatoes and wilted baby Jem lettuce now
if you've never eaten cooked lettuce
before you have to try it cuz it is
absolutely delicious hot pan olive oil
and these are the outside leaves of the
baby Jem the nice big thick robust
leaves so into the pan and quickly so
them
out
beautiful now soate new potato these are
part boiled so they've been boiled for
about 4 and 1 half to 5 minutes and then
we leave the skins on and just cut them
in half and we part boil them a to
soften them and B so they actually stay
nice and whole and then get some garlic
and some
thyme and what we do with the garlic is
we just get the Clover
garlic we don't need to peel it we just
get the clove like that on the board and
just
Crush so that sort of crushes oozies the
scent of the garlic into the potatoes
and then perfumes
them and great for flavor and then into
the
pan again nice hot
pan now is to get some really nice color
on the potatoes and then 30 seconds
before the potatoes come out of the pan
just a little knob of but in there so
gives that really nice gold brown color
on the potato now Christmas is almost
here and my turkeyy time is running
out I'm trying to grow my own Christmas
dinner and hu furly whst is the main man
when it comes to small
Holdings hello mate are you well very
well good to see you Sand's come early
well I'll say yes what's in there the
presents are not for you and they're not
even for the kids no they're for the
birds he's brought the ingredients for
his own recipe turkey feed special
Christmas treat so what's in there exact
okay let's have a
look the main mix that I think you
should get them on for the last two
weeks is whole grain barley some walnuts
fantastic so we got barley we got barley
whole barley grains and oats and walnuts
and walnuts now that is an old uh turkey
rarus trick just the natural oils in
that just give them a little bit of a
boost amazing so we're almost feeding
them their perfect sort of Christmas
lunch send off and aren't we we're
giving them the best possible Christmas
dinner so that you can have the best
possible Christmas dinner fated what you
going to do with the apples I'll bring
them out we'll have a play with them a
bit later on let's go with this first
excellent what do you think the space
this is a good space you could do a lot
here you could go beyond the turkeys for
sure you've just about got enough space
here for a pair of pigs maybe an idea
for next year but I mean I'd let you
break that one to the misses you know
that okay let's see if they're a tool
interested in my special
mix how about that straight away they
seem to like it straight away I think
they could just have a little bit more
stimulation while they're out on the
lawn you haven't got a croquet set have
you okay here we go now lovely set
Gordon yeah amazing hasn't hasn't hasn't
seen a lot of use no it hasn't seen
first time you know Q thinks that
pecking apples hanging from croquet
Hoops will relax the turkeys and a
relaxed bird is a tasty
bird when my friend asked me that
croquet set have you used it yet I got
you for your birthday got a great idea
for him now so yes it's been put to
bloody good use even the river Cottage
birds don't get this sort of
treat fantastic if these turkeys start
pecking the apples I'll be very excited
but it looks like the turkeys don't want
to play the
game slight problem with Nigel and deia
they're obviously guys now look at the
weight and the size yeah that must have
come as a surprise yeah that it was a
big surprise what do you reckon I mean
change their names or kind of put deia
as the new Hugh or Nigel for Nigella
Gordon I don't know I mean it's very
flattering but I'd like to talk to you a
little bit about this whole name thing
it's possible that you made a little bit
of a mistake naming them ready possible
because it's that much easier to form a
a Sentimental attachment to a creature
if you give it a name uhuh it's actually
quite interesting when you see how
attached the kids have become my oldest
Oscar he's never had a problem with that
until last year one of our cows gave
birth of course the car was a pretty
little black and white C Oscar
christened it lovely and we had lovely
and lovely had a name and Oscar who for
a couple of years had been very calm and
understanding about the whole grow it
eat it thing suddenly he had a named
animal that he had a personal
relationship and then it that for the
first time we had problems you've got to
start saying to them which is looking
the tastiest which one's going to the
oven first which is going in the oven
first which bits do you like do do you
like the leg or the wing or will you you
know that sort of thing how are we going
to cook them taking something to
slaughter is an emotional occasion you
can't have totally put that out the way
no you've just got to work through it
for me the way to work through it is to
think these creatures have lived very
well I've done the best I can for them
yeah absolutely and and the big question
of course next Autumn will be you know
Daddy are we going to get some more
turkeys for Christmas that's what I want
to hear yeah yeah that is what you want
to hear or pigs for spring pigs for
Easter chickens and pigs for Easter
turkeys for Christmas I can lend you a
cow [__] you can get up every morning
and do some
milking fitted in over there
damn the thing is though once you start
rearing your own livestock it's so
lovely you just won't want to stop yeah
and you'll want to try something
different and keep moving on and before
you know it Gordon this whole place is
just going to be it's going to be a
little farm it's going to be great
sugar let's go four now yes let's go big
boy
in right stop so what have you done to
that so uh the flame caught on the P
yeah okay yeah if it's caught and it's
burnt get rid of it yeah of course you
do some more wake up come on we go to
all this extent we make these amazing
wellingtons and the Pan's too hot yeah
of course we're going to do some more
okay let's
go First
Slice come on an watch look there in
second slice now look at the beef it's
absolutely perfectly cooked cuz they've
rested beautifully okay yeah nice and
pink in the center okay and we just want
to season that lightly with a bit of
rock salt okay let's go now the
presentation is really important you
know that we're going to start off with
the lettuce at the top of the plate at
12:00 at 9:00 we got the vegetables and
then at 6:00 put this lovely slice of
Wellington now this is a classic
vinegarette that's been thickened with
mustard we're just going to drizzle the
warm vinegret over the salad and the
sauteed potatoes
now what would those customer be
thinking if you sent all that bitter
burnt lettuce they' be pissed off yeah
of course they' be pissed off cuz I
would be as well good well don't send it
then let's go clean the plates good boy
up abass come on you can help out nice
not on the rim not on the rim there
first three or four tables went out
lovely it stays like that yes good must
have vinegarette good boy let's go and
take the garlic out let's
go inside the lettuce and just a little
bit over the potatoes come on trays out
come on work with me please you're
standing gping at me like you're in an
art exhibition wake
up go they look beautiful right you made
a mistake like that yeah I don't want to
see you sucking there like some big you
to come to come back then your face
let's go wakey
[Music]
wakey
Richard how are you I'm very well G how
are you doing very on thank you good to
see you how was your main course very
very good you enjoyed it I never had
cooked lettuce before now do you
actually cook at home I do yes and what
kind of sort of food you cook oh simple
fish in the oven potatoes being Scottish
I have to potatoes everything yes in
fact if you sent me to a desert island
said what could you eat I'd probably
have to say potato I hear behind the
scenes you slightly intimidated about
confronting waiters when you go to a
restaurant I remember the first
restaurant I actually complained in that
the Tomato the grilled tomato was black
really and I I I choked in my mouth and
as I said it and I said look I'm I'm
sorry but this this tomato was uneatable
and you said was it l and that was it
that was it off way but it's really
interesting listen to you saying that
you're sort of uncomfortable with
complaining when the character you
played for so many years was a constant
pain in the ass well Victor M wouldn't
know his way around a good restaurant
unfortunately no whenever you want to um
you know complain to it becomes a bit of
a confusion because there's so many
waiters always complain to the m or the
manager yeah now I've got a bit of a
food quiz tongue twister for you qu yes
which part of a sheep's head is an
Arabic food delicacy the eyes what round
sugary thing with a whole in the middle
does Homer Simpson love to eat a donut a
donut it's exactly that well done no I
do love donuts my mother made a good
donut I love donuts one insect makes
Honey a bee a bee fantastic if you
follow up yeah what do you do with your
food that's left on the plate put it in
the bin yeah we no
you what you leave it you leave it you
leave it exactly you've got them all
right well done I
[Music]
eat well Jonathan Ross paid me £10,000
to say I'm sorry I'll pay you £1 here
now Richard you're an absolute star
thank you so much it an absolute
pleasure lovely best wishes thank you
cheers I don't believe it I can't
believe you said it I really like my
meat bloody I like it really really rare
and uh this didn't disappoint whenever I
go to restaurants it's never quite rare
enough so this was really good for me
Beef Wellington was absolutely super I
mean it it really was the meat was
fantastic melt in the mouth and the
mustard in the beef wellington was a
rare touch really nice I I don't even
normally red mink but it really
surprised me because it was so light and
it was so easy to cut and it was it was
it was easy on your palette and it kind
of went down really easily I usually
when I eat red meat it was like quite
tough or something like that but this
time it was it was really delicious and
the whole thing was great good to see
you um did you enjoy enjoy your Beef
Wellington abolutely stunning yes would
you try cooking that at home we were
just talking about that yeah definitely
and the Wellington in particular is
great for a large party whether it's six
of you or eight of you even 10 of you
one nice whole fill it scared of willing
to though because I always kind of think
to myself how do you get the pastry
crisp on the outside when you don't cook
it for very long at all how does that
work that's a good question first of all
when you start cook in the Wellington
you start cooking at 200° and you cook
it at 200° for about 8 to 10 minutes
till it gets color right and then you
turn it down to 180 and cook for about a
further 20 minutes so it gets really
nice and crispy it's a CO of phrase from
col far was a bleeding delish but uh no
as a meal in the hole was absolutely
beautiful the uh cut of beef was just
tender delicious uh the mushrooms loved
that and the lettuce was uh different
but uh loved it as
well next on the menu how clean is my
kitchen I can't believe the mess look at
the state of it how clean is your hair
wait till you see the mess I make of you
de later I cook some real fast food just
a smell quicker than a microwave meal
and Giles debunks detox does does detox
actually mean
anything welcome back to the FW now next
up is pudding where Kim andagi from how
clean is your house are actually going
to try and attempt to beat me with their
recipe for a trifle she's so nervous
actually ladies can we get going nice
Clean Hands don't get nervous cuz I'm
here don't start getting twistery I
affect men like that you
know dear now I'm doing a bit of a sort
of straightforward classic trifle um
we're doing a trifle with caramelized
peaches and Clementine very festive done
with the most amazing customers made
with vanilla and then a nice twist at
the end we're going to get some salted
peanuts and turn them into a caramel
salted peanut
agie tell me what you doing okay I'm I'm
feting out my egg yolks and the sugar
and vanilla case I'm going to put a wee
bit of corn flour in cuz I'm slightly
nervous that it'll split I don't want
that to happen okay and I've also can I
just say I've made my own triple sponges
here with goose eggs I bought from a
that's fantastic you may as well go home
in my opinion oh dear I we've got to
bloody well win this we have still got
to win this so for my tri I'm going to
make um the most amazing cusser but very
simple cusser not like kimages this is
sort of done with sugar eggs and fresh
vanilla pods do you know what I've used
the wrong cream I love you already you
swear like a chef if agie wins he's
going to cry like a baby I sense that
you know I'm GL determined to win sorry
I'm determined to win I'm so I'm afraid
I'm very
competitive now what's the most
important tip you could give to anyone
out there about keeping their kitchen at
home clean what would you say first keep
your um wiping out cloth absolutely
clean stop spreading the bacteria and
clean as you go absolutely clean as you
go that's that's right clean as you go
and get everyone else to mck in so the
peaches we're just going to quarter
roast them off in a little bit of sugar
the exciting thing about camiz in these
peaches it's done with the most amazing
sugar very fragrant Mavado sugar and
that gives a really nice sort of Rich
syrupy color onto the
peaches will you stop that for goodness
sake This Ss a big man you know dear
feel like back in the kitchen bit of
here de need to take off these love
hands are growing a bit I don't mind
H
ow [__] I feel like I got a baby r on my
back putting them off as food for God's
sake if they're trying to distract me it
really is working know that cuz I can't
can't just concentrate on anything right
now God I've never had a 64-year-old
grab my boobs like that and now I'm
giving the Swiss roll a little bit of a
sort of um bit of a Scottish effect I'm
sort of dousing it and gr on you uh can
I just say I can't believe the mess look
at the state of it how clean is your
house wait till you see the mess I make
of you dear ler look at the floor
deliberate I've roed the peach and the
Clementine off in musada Sugar they've
sort of um been caramelized Bey colored
and now I'm just going to add them to
the
sponge and then we're going to add the
custard they're very splashy things
though I know not only is my brain set
but the custards about to set so we're
going to put that in the fridge the cool
down and once that's nice and cool we're
going to finish it with a creme fresh
finish with Mavado sugar and hopefully
get rid of that honey monster I'm
finishing my trifle off with some salted
caramel peanuts it's just salted peanuts
in a pan a Sprinkle of
sugar and a Sprinkle of salt but this is
not any salt this is not a powder salt
this is called selda G it's a sort of
rare gray sea salt very powerful very
delicious and it goes well when you make
a
caramel and just leave them to cool down
rolling pin break them up and sprinkle
them top of your
trifle cut it on top now most
importantly get it in the fridge and let
it set for about 35 40
minutes now I've been in another woman's
kitchen this week and like so many women
I've met she reckons she hasn't got time
to cook I'm so busy because I run my own
theater School hence why I never have
time to cook I'd really like to learn to
cook something that's fast obviously it
doesn't take too too much preparation
time something that's quick something
that's healthy something that's not too
complicated which will get my confidence
off a bit I think it's really important
to be able to cook especially when I've
got a husband and a little baby and to
eat it all up I'm very embarrassed that
I can't actually okay now why can't you
cook few reasons really mostly because
my mom can't cook really so you're
blaming her I'm to totally blaming her
yeah but you must be able to do
absolutely these well the simple things
surely I can do toast toast ready Breck
ready Breck oh dear my solution is a
fast food fix but real fast food pasta
fresh tag telli um something that is not
too complicated we could use dried
Linguini or spaghetti but this is a
fresh Elli the secret is of course
cooking the pasta very very simply and
boiling water salted boiling water Touch
of olive oil in there and you can mix
all these things in there things like um
marinated Arch Hearts um and you know
olives smokes um petta great for pasta
dishes easy to fry really full of flavor
these General things should be in your
store cupbo you know that I'm going to
teach Rachel a simple pasta dish that
she can cook in 10 minutes flat use some
fresh crab some fresh um chili some
lemon juice and parley through there and
just mix it up that's all it is the
hardest thing of course is just cooking
the pasta apart from that everything
else is self-explanatory first thing
what you do is put on a pan of water put
the water in it's not going to go so
take the pot oh sorry it's not coming
from the kettle no no dear oh dear the
lights are on but Rachel's gone home
okay chopping board on here please yeah
when was the last time you chopped a
chili yeah never never good okay get the
chili and just rub it together like that
mhm okay and what that does it loosens
all the little seeds in the center right
once you've taken the top off slide down
the center like that right okay and then
just open it up with your fingers look
just push all the way down and what that
does it gets rid of the seeds and the
seeds are actually hotter than the chili
okay that's what worries me about
chilies yeah well I mean stinging my
eyes and most important thing now is of
course by the time you finish chopping
it okay just wash your hands very very
quickly get the chili just take nice
nice small slices there three
ingredients so far pasta crab and chili
now just need some parsley yeah and it's
flat leaf parsley so it helps us cut
down the strength of chili and just make
it a lot more flavorsome water's coming
up to the boil nice handful of pasta
yeah into the water please so that's the
other thing I never know how much pasta
to cook pass with the bowl that you're
going to serve in you get your bowl yeah
okay and you look there okay now that
looks a nice portion yeah yeah so
spoonful of chilies in there yep good
crab meat in good excellent you're
standing away from the stove and you
look like you're really nervous and
scared of it get close to it I'm scared
of the fat yeah no you got to get close
to it and you look like you're in
control of it yes how can you handle 320
kids and you can't handle one little F
I'm scared of the fat no no it's cooking
that's called cooking and I want you to
squeeze some fresh lemon juice in there
fresh parsley over there okay nice so
lift off one strand and we want what
we're looking for is a bit of a bite in
there MCE that's quite firm is that's
that's just just just about right into
your pasta now it's really important you
get all that crab meat mixed into it now
mix that up okay but look you're not
doing it well get the spoon in there
again I want you to mix all that in
there like that okay all of it in there
together yeah quicker than a microwave
meal um without a doubt yeah two really
nice bowls just a smell yeah it's just
gorgeous T so that's a meal for two in
less than 10 minutes here you go the
truth
M I'm
impressed I can't believe you've done
this I know you did it all well not too
much help little bit of help from the
boss right James happy very happy it's
really nice really nice don't need to be
scared of something stick to something
really really simple and just climb the
ladder with it yeah we use crab you know
next time maybe prawns next time roasted
Vine tomatoes and you know just maybe
think about it during the day and pick
up the stuff on the way home yeah no
excuses cuz
good you stop do not stop and stay in
there Madam thank you thank
you okay excited I'm so nervous let's
just put them side by side I always like
to see them before you start serving
them yeah like have a quick look
underneath yeah lots of jam too much Jam
actually sponge and um looks a lot of
lot of alcohol shaking down the bottom
there can I just say good luck first cuz
I think you'll need it okay
okay what I wish I'd got frozen
raspberries cuz these fresh ones have
got no flavor whatsoever yeah what do we
expect he don't be looking your fingers
you oh is that a oh he stuck it in there
oh God is that awful okay John
Baptist yeah I'm going to serve mine
first because these ladies are messing
around again we are not messing one
trying to grab my bollocks the other
one's trying to pickle it we're there
now might have a little taste while
we're in fact we got
St don't be funny don't be funny here's
SS oh star it's so
alcoholic oh God that is very good I
just need a little bit more I needed a
little bit more time cooking the peaches
that is very good that's beautiful oh
God that is so good I'm really happy you
like it you know this week's tasters
I'll try my dessert
first I must I quite like the
composition I like the colors and that I
like it because there good balance
between salt and U so sweet number two
nowk you it's very this one is sloppy
delicious I find it too sweet for me
both of them Julia did you did you
prefer dessert number one or thiser
number two I think I would definitely go
for the second one I go for number one
the number two is definitely the best
let's get the frogging where is he
Baptist put these two ladies out the
misery yeah and tell me who's the winner
of course who's the winner the winner is
this week yes Kim and AGI oh get out no
you're joking aren't
you God I'm so exciting I'm so sorry us
it so much better oh God you can't who's
tasting them up there yes indeed they
got they got crap yeah I iest I suggest
we get their mouth cleaned out are you
sure yes I am I'll piss
off oh my God I'm so sorry cuz yours are
so much better actually really so much
better oh dear those two women you know
that they're absolutely obsessed with
cleaning they do seem to be no they're
just mad I mean nearly as mad as you are
with your organic food I'm not as
especially mad they they are mad if if
cleanliness is Next to Godliness you
have been cooking there against the pope
and the Archbishop of Canter now you've
been finding out about sort of cleaning
out your insides right well
theoretically cleaning out your insides
it's a big boom thing this
detoxing every year more and more people
getting into this thing it's a kind of
puritanical guilt thing they've been
drinking they've been smoking they've
been eating fatty foods fast food and
they think you know they can't change
their lifestyle because they so they oh
what can I do buy a little pot of
something or some pills or go on a
regime drinking booze smoking eating
fast food and all the other things you
do on a night out all the other things
you do in party season have a downside
they make you feel terrible in the
morning because you're filling your body
with toxins now you can either lay off
the fun stuff all together which doesn't
sound like fun or you can look at
detoxing there's a whole industry
devoted to it all sorts of products all
sorts of ideas but do any of them work
to find out I suppose I'll have to get
toxic what about what about the the
detox products you can buy in the shops
have you ever tried one of them yes have
you really what kind of a product just a
a 3-day deto really yeah why did you try
it um you were feeling terrible or
something no I think as a woman you did
to lose weight really and did you lose
weight no I think they were an absolute
waste of time you gain energy and you
gain you gain yeah you gain stuff it's
it's a it's a great
[Applause]
thing eat drink and be merry for
tomorrow we
detox
um it's the uh morning after the night
before as it so often is uh and I happen
to have four or five days in front of me
when I don't have to eat and drink and
do terrible toxic things and this would
be a good time for me to detox I don't
really have time or the inclination to
live on cabbage soup and citrus fruit
and water for for the rest of my life
fortunately there is a range of products
on the market which claim to be able to
detox me in 3 to 5 days but with so many
things to choose from how on Earth am I
supposed to know which one is the
best someone who might be able to tell
me is Katherine Collins Chief dietitian
at St George's hospital she points out
that some detox products include
laxatives which will help cleanse your
body in the way it knows best in your
poo that makes you feel like you've
cleansed your body to PO anywhere well
absolutely but these things are you know
sexing up your poo a little bit aren't
they and then so this is basically sexy
poo rather than it is because you paid a
lot for it does deto actually mean
anything it's the buzzword of the health
industry these dayses it mean anything
at all it means nothing at all it's a
marketing term not not a medical term at
all our bodies are treating the
chemicals that we get from diet from
inhale inhaling fumes from our stressful
Lifestyles the things we produce our
bodies are dealing with that if they
didn't we'd be in a hospital we'd be
dead you're buying um an expensive
adjunct to a normal diet and these sort
of products wouldn't make a rubbish diet
good there's no law defining what a
detox product is so it's perfectly legal
to put the word on any product without
having to prove it's
true Bo Bo has become one of the UK's
biggest retailers of detox products
since it introduce them 3 years ago in
January after the party season their
sales shoot up by 40% how how does the
detox work how do they do that how do
they knock out they detox they support
your body to do what it it can do of its
own as course they help you you maximize
that potential it does have some
information here about the essentials
when do detoxing and obviously tells you
what all the key ingredients are vitamin
C vitamin EIT which you but you you I
mean that's they're vitamin supplements
that people might be taking anyway
potentially yes glutathione is not one
that you would traditionally find that's
and what is glutathione that's a it's um
it's a really powerful antioxidant
that's naturally stored in the liver
right and the liver is one of the main
organs in the body for detoxing if it's
stored naturally why do I need more um
again you may not be guessing adequate
from your diet cuz there are those who
would say in the kind of in the
conventional medical industry that the
whole notion of detox is is just a sort
of myth there are different points of
view I admit that um but I think it it
comes back to the way we live our lives
nowadays we know the body is designed to
detox but it was designed you know a
long long time ago and maybe not
equipped for the sort of pollution and
the environment and the lifestyles that
we have nowadays and I think something
that can actually support your body in
detoxing and kind of Kickstart a
healthier diet has to be beneficial the
the benefits of of detoxing are proven
um by I think by and the customers who
tell us they really feel better they
feel the but they don't do lots of kind
of you know Placebo tests with you don't
tend to because at the end of the day
these are nutritional supplements
they're things that you would also find
in food they're not they're not
medicines if spending money makes you
feel better then go ahead and buy detox
products but I haven't been able to find
any medical evidence which suggest that
you need to so I'm just going to stick
with a glass of water
[Music]
next on the menu the commies find out
who's staying and who's going home hand
on my heart Chef five hand on your heart
hand on your M that's a bit High I
discover what England manager Fen does
the night before a big match cuz he's
banned the players from having a little
bit of Nookie before the game so it must
be the same for you no well and Kim
charms the diners with Aggie's trifle
touch your
face
oh my God Kimmy my darling yes you made
the dessert so you're going to have to
help me serve it now yes okay right off
why don't you actually go to the table
start sering that way we keep you out
the kitchen yeah exactly thank you so
much thank you thank you so much small
shut your
face
so's best de do you feel really happy
now that you're serving your own dessert
here I never thought that was going to
be possible you know that think I feel
so humble I know it's only a trifle but
however it's a winning trifle do you
know what I am so effing chaed I can't
tell you at the end of the day I thought
yours was better I really do I really
mean that but I am so pleased they
didn't like the salted peanuts wow you
know what these plebs are like come oned
peanuts unbelievable please come on
let's
Go's come off the let's
go my wife does an excellent trial but
this was really good and I have to be
100% loyal and say my wife's is better
this is my wife's
trifle and it's exceptional of course
and she's been practicing all weekend oh
no hi enjoy your dessert usually I don't
need dessert I like to prepare and make
dessert I used to do it but I don't eat
dessert but it was lovely but it was
yours no no I lost the challenge today
this is oh that's why it's so good yeah
oh you also I don't like it so oh thank
you um too much alcohol in there you
know that a little bit well never is
enough alcohol yeah I see that Italian
passion coming through he a little bit
too yeah now when was the last time you
cooked at home last night last night and
what did you cook I'm fascinated to find
out melan Pana you know how to made it
explain to me I'm going to teach you I'd
love you to teach me how to make melan
Jana P what the is
it oh sorry obino B yeah B with
mozzarella it's
mozzarella it's is s it's fantastic one
of the best ples it's lovely this when
enjoy it yes he does he enjoys his food
doesn't he yes definitely does yeah
you're cooking or does he prer eating
out no no no no I do yes he helps me I
can't imagine spending in the kitchen
standing there with a penny on no he
he's doing well having uh you botom
about I
really s slice that shalot thinner
please I don't know we're working
together we a team we're a
team what kind of food does he like
eating before a match is it similar to
the players or I I never ask him what he
had so you're not with him the night
before no I'm not no I'm not with him
the night before I'm going to change his
L yeah I'll say because rules it must be
cuz he's banned the players from having
a little bit Nookie before the game so
it must be the same for you no well it
difference players and a manager
but that's
great rumor has it you find the kitchen
the sexiest place in the house that is
it the place they too easy yes and do
you have wood or granite or marble
what's on your services uh it's wood w
so you got no carpet Burns no it's wood
on the floor but it's wood somewhere as
in a marble now you're living in London
do you actually miss real true classic
Italian food or one thing we really were
missing and actually i' have uh have
very good view it's a little present
view it is lemon it looks very strong
whatever it is is I'm going to explain
what it is
iSell looks like olive oil exactly but
it's a lemon cello H dangerous it's
quite dangerous because this is close to
40% alcohol so it's like a a lemon laure
and this is your mom's recipe yes this
is my mother recipe she just sent over
today that smells amazing you know that
is so let me I want to know Chin Chin
what they say in ch salute Sal you knock
it straight
back oh
Dam usually
I you g that to the players last week at
half time against Argentina my God is
that why they got their act together
finally they so good you an absolute
star now forgive you a kiss will some be
annoyed no no nice to see you see you
congratulations thank you take care
thank you go I feel
[Laughter]
pissed
it's time for me to tell the commies who
will stay on for the semi-finals and who
will go home right T yes yes our best
Che yeah well done to you both uh Tama
if you could change something today what
would you do I'd make sure a couple of
dishes like the the lettuce was cooked
enough right stop so what have you done
to that so uh the Flames C on the P okay
yeah if it's caught and it's burnt get
rid of it yeah of course you do some
more wake up come on give yourself a
mark out of 10 what would you give
yourself four four that's generous a
bass five five hand on my heart Chef
five hand on your heart hand on your
bollocks mate that's a bit High look at
that there yeah that's clumsy yeah
that's correct next time get it right
let's start again yeah Third Time Lucky
scops in the pan now hello this time I
want I want you to really think about
how much money we're wasting and I want
you seriously to wake up and get a grip
the person that I'm going to be um
sending home
is
abass you're leaving the kitchen TMA
you're staying and four out of 10 was
high not bad but masses of room for
improvement yes sir and thank you
however I don't feel that you're that
passionate about becoming a great chef
but you did
well and you tried very
hard thank you very much now put a smile
on that beard this is like the cut for a
footballer for me um yeah it's kind of
like that or or the Olympic Games for an
athlete that does 100 m I'm like an
athlete of the
kitchen